l'accord est la seule alternative
laurent et white meilleure façon pour
écarter la possibilité d'un audit et que
ce parlement approuve un accord avec
l'union européenne
c'est ce que ce gouvernement cherche à
réaliser la seule autre façon d'éviter
un break site sans accord c'est de
révoquer l'article 50 ce qui
signifierait restent égaux dans l'union
européenne
tout juste at elle pu annoncer la
suppression des frais de dossier pour
les ressortissants européens qui
souhaitent rester au royaume uni
il faut dire que les partenaires
européens n'ont pas franchement envie de
re ligue aussi à neuf semaines et demie
du brics est alors pour comprendre les
différents scénarios possibles j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir gabriel grésillons
bon jour en jour est un des deux
correspondant des échos ici à bruxelles
et vous suivez ce feuilleton du brésil
quelle est l'ambiance au parlement
européen ces derniers jours écoutez à
bruxelles en général au parlement mais
aussi au conseil c'est à dire chez les
états membres c'est une ambiance très
particulière une ambiance d'attentes
d'inquiétude et je dirais aussi de
lassitude
quand même voir chez certains une forme
d'exaspération
alors ben on peut on peut balayer tous
ces éléments je pense que globalement
tout le monde se demande où va theresa
may et depuis le dernier sommet européen
de décembre il ya il ya une inquiétude
qui est assez forte parce qu'elle a
donné l'impression à ce moment là de ne
pas avoir véritablement de plans elle
implore régulièrement les européens lui
donner un peu plus mais on ne sait pas
exactement où elle veut aller
on en parle déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines mais le risque d'un audi
l'appareil de plus en plus grands
concrètement qu'est ce que ça signifie
s'il n'y a pas d'accord que se
passe-t-il 29 mars prochain c'est
difficile de l'anticiper mais
globalement ça va ressembler un peu au
chaos d'une manière ou d'une autre alors
ce sera un chaos qu'on va réussir à à
limiter si on fait plein de petites
mesures sectorielles pour permettre
malgré tout quand même aux avions
d'atterrir et de décoller voilà donc on
peut trouver des moyens temporaires de
limiter la violence du choc mais pour
les 27 fin pour les européens il est
très clair qu'il faut absolument pas que
ces mini mesures sectorielles viennent
en fait faire disparaître les faits du
brésil donc leur vocation ce sera de
faire une transition en douceur de
quelques mois mais dans les faits on va
tout d'un coup se retrouver avec non
seulement peut-être des barrières
tarifaires mais toute une série de
problématiques de respect de règles et
donc en fait les flux de transfert de
marchandises pour ne parler que de ça il
ya bien d'autres aspects mais vont être
extrêmement compliqué donc ce serait je
pense que c'est quand même malgré tout
en dépit des postures c'est un scénario
que tout le monde cherche à éviter et
qui n'est pas si probable que ça pour
l'instant on voit et vous